book TV is live today from Chicago the
printers roll it fest in its 28th year
expecting over 125,000 visitors today
we're bringing you coverage from
University Center next Shelley Murphy
and Kevin :
talk about their book whitey bulger
America's most-wanted gangster and the
manhunt that brought him to justice
[Music]
annual Chicago Tribune printers roll it
fest we would like to give a special
thank you to all of our sponsors who
have helped make today such a success
today's program will be broadcast live
on c-span two's book TV and if there is
time at the end of the queue at the end
of the session for Q&A we ask that you
use the microphone in the middle of the
room so that our audience at home is
able to hear your question if you would
like to watch this program again please
note coverage will re-air at 11:00 p.m.
Central time on Saturday and midnight
Central Time on Sunday please keep the
spirit of litt fest going all year with
a subscription to printers row the
tribunes premium book section fiction
series and membership program visit the
printers roll Welcome Center at Harrison
and Dearborn for special lip fest
subscription rates and perks including
mullet fest tote bags and posters
finally the author's books will be on
sale in this University Center right in
the hog show all of you saw it as you
came in and they'll be signing books in
the arts room which is right here to our
to the left I should say my right your
left I ask that you would please turn
off your cellphone's and electronic
devices now and without further ado I
would like to welcome and introduce our
moderator mr. Phil Rosenthal of the
Chicago Tribune
thank you thank you all for coming out
on a beautiful day it sort of begs us
all outside but here we are we don't get
a lot of those here I'm Phil Rosenthal
with the Chicago Tribune I write a
business column I'm with Kevin Cullen
and Shelley Murphy of the Boston Globe
who are here not to do scouting on the
Chicago Blackhawks oh that's not what I
said
but but to talk about their their new
book on whitey bulger who's the Boston
mobster caught on the lam after what 16
years and first of all let's let's get
the bona fides out you guys have been
Boston journalists for quite a long time
at this point
somebody said between us it's sort of
like what 60 years yeah we've been we've
been chasing him combined total of
probably 25 I mean 25 feet so like 50
years between us Wow and and and
although at this point in journalism you
know having a job is its own reward
you've got an arm full of trophies along
the way Pulitzer Prize couple of Polk
Awards between it's it's it's an
impressive list you know it's a it's a
wonderful book the thing I was reminded
of at the very beginning of it something
oh when I was a kid my father was taking
a friend of mine to go see Butch Cassidy
and the Sundance Kid and as he dropped
us off he said you know remember
whatever the movie makes of them they
are the bad guys and the other thing
that it reminded me of was the the old
line from Mel Brooks in the 2000 year
old man where he's talked about exact
about Robin Hood and he said you know
Carl Reiner asked him you know he says
what about Robin Hood he stole from the
rich and gave to the poor he said it's
nonsense
he stole from everybody and kept
everything and Ryan or says well how did
that happen and he goes well he had a
guy named Marty the press agent Marty
would go out and tell everyone he got
from the rich he gave to the poor who
knew he hit you so hard over the head
you didn't know what had happened and
and I I was thinking about when it you
know
the whitey bulger story and and and
stories about pretty much every mobster
these days there is this myth and I
don't know whether it's that we want to
believe the myth or whether they want us
to believe the myth they all seem to
have myths tell us a little bit about
the myth of Whitey Bulger and and where
it starts to sort of come apart when
when flushed against reality Shelley and
I sat down to do the book one of the
things we're trying to look for several
narrative arcs and one of them was the
myth mate myth making of Whitey Bulger
so whitey balls are from a very early
age when he was a young teenage criminal
he lived in the housing project the
first one built in New England and he he
had a car when no one else had a car and
when he wasn't driving around with his
buxom girlfriend Jackie McAuliffe he
would be out scouting and he wasn't
scouting for criminal opportunities he's
looking for old ladies so when he'd see
some old lady trundling down with a bit
with the groceries he'd pull over jump
out swing open the door take the
groceries off and put them in the back
seat drive the old ladies home I was a
very conscious decision and the end you
know when everybody they call it stoop
talking in the in the projects people
would stand out on the stoop and just
trade gossip the stories and everything
and everyone said but while so I say at
Jimmy balls of his a hoodlum and all the
old ladies well now wait a minute
Jimmy's a lovely young man he gave me a
ride home from the market the other day
and and he was so conscious of doing
that and he did it right through and he
was the one the difference of all Bulger
and it wasn't just his narrative that he
was pushing out there he had a very
influential family and particularly as a
younger brother bill who became his
advocate particularly in what he went to
prison and Bill Bulger was out there
propagating the myth to bill Bowdre said
to my face on several occasions my
brother would never touch drugs and
Jimmy Bulger is Whitey Bulger was very
good at sophistry so he'll tell you he
was never an informant because he never
testified against anybody and put them
in prison
whereas we found this informant file of
700 pages he very much was an informant
he would tell he would tell you that you
know he like this as a criminal that he
had all these scruple
and he was all he never touched drugs in
fact we have a scene he does he's in the
car with drugs but the reality is he
made millions and millions of dollars by
shaking down drug dealers and letting
drugs go through the neighborhood of
South Boston I lived there in the 80s
and the 90s there was more drugs per
capita in South Boston than any
neighborhood in the city and why he's
got that on his hands and and you
mentioned Billy Bulger his younger
brother and and and Billy would end up
becoming president of the Massachusetts
Senate President of the University of
Massachusetts even when he was in the
State House he was he was succeeded by
you know the future mayor of Boston ray
Flynn so I mean we're not talking just a
quiet power broker this was this was a
guy who was out there and up there and
important they both came out of this
family the father had been injured in
lost an arm but more importantly where
that part of those projects were South
Boston tell us a little bit well I mean
South Boston you know is a neighborhood
where there was a real Irish ethos even
though there were many different ethnic
groups that lived there the the
neighborhood really identified itself as
Irish and if even in the public schools
the Albanian kids were forced to sing
Irish songs so I mean it's a
neighborhood where loyalty meant
everything loyalty to family loyalty to
neighborhood there was a lot of pride in
the neighborhood and you know it's
interesting on Billy Bulger who you know
as you said Phil would be you know was
probably the most powerful politician in
the state for many years he describes
growing up in South Boston and very sort
of idealistic terms about how close-knit
it was and you know all of the even
though nobody had very much and it when
they were fairly poor that they were you
know the kids hanging together outside
playing games kick the key in football
never but so there was a lot of you know
it was sort of not unusual for one
family to have someone who would be a
priest
our politician or a police officer and
another who would be a gangster it was
not all that unusual in that city at
that time one of Whitey's closest
associates Kevin weeks also grew up in
the projects and two of his brothers
went to Harvard University and
yeah Kevin could have gone there he was
so brilliant but his father was prouder
of Kevin for working his way into the
position of Whitey's top enforcer than
he wasn't the two that went to Harvard
so there was this sort of culture about
the place and loyalty did mean
everything and that takes us to how this
story really starts with whitey being
cultivated as an FBI informant it is an
FBI agent who grew up in the projects
with the Bulger family who recruits
whitey to be an FBI informant that agent
John Connolly the the thing that was
interesting and and you know there are
so many interesting aspects about the
Boulder story whether it's even you know
even the stuff where he's part of that
CIA research project where they you know
when he's in prison they're you know who
knows what the lasting effects of giving
him LSD what you'll hear it during this
trial believe me yeah but but you know
the the really striking thing is this
this intertwined corruption of the mob
and the FBI if you can separate them
right in this case so so they they they
thought well first of all I should ask
you did they think they were making an
informant out of him or did it or was
this simply a you know a bad idea
corrupt at its core one of the things
Shelly and I talked about this while we
were planning the book how could this
have happened in any other city and my
belief is no because there is no other
city whether you're talking about New
York Chicago Philadelphia Cleveland LA
Atlanta there's no city where you have
these two strands of organized crime
one's Irish one is Italian in all those
other cities the Mafia is by far bigger
more powerful more lucrative in Boston
it wasn't that way so one of the things
we tried to show is this all went Square
or on one pair all went pear-shaped in
the 60s when Bobby Kennedy went a J
Edgar Hoover and said you need to get
syriza now at this point Hoover didn't
even except there wasn't Mallya and he
was ordered by the Attorney General you
have to develop a strategy so they
decided to go after the Mafia but that
it really didn't pick up until the 70s
and like I said that's an
national policy the problem with
national policies they don't take into
account regional differences and in
Boston that model did not fit but what
yeah so you had basically the FBI agents
were told do whatever you have to do to
make our policy work so in the 1960s
what they did is they play God they
decided who would be killed there was an
Irish gang war in the 60s and one of the
60 men were killed in it and why he was
very lucky because he was locked up at
the time so statistically they've got a
very high chance it would have been a
perpetrator or a victim of that violence
instead he comes out to a decimated
landscape it's wide open for anybody
with opportunity and some smarts and
some viciousness and he had all those
things and so he goes in there and now
Conley is very cynical Conley's from the
hood and he's saying the MA and the
other thing about the FBI you get
promotions you get base salary raises
based on your ability not to make cases
but to turn informants and so you want
to have as many credible informants in
your file it's it's a notch in your belt
you want to get a top echelon informant
so when John Conley recruits whitey
balls were in 1975 he gets to say this
guy is the leading member of the sees
the head of the the mob in South Boston
that looks good for the FBI but the idea
that he was going to give him anything
on the Mafia is a joke he didn't know
any that the Italians wouldn't at old
whitey if his pants were on fire and and
the reality is his criminal associate
Steve CV Fleming didn't know a lot about
the Mafia had actually been recruited by
the Mafia several times always turned
them down saying now I want to stay on
my own and so Connelly does it for two
reasons first of all it looks good for
him but it's it's there's an ulterior
motive and it goes back to the hood it
goes back to Southie and that was to
protect the Bulger family to save them
from the ignominy of whitey being
dragged off to prison right but the the
backtrack a little bit
the reason this we're talking about this
is you know people saying well this is
what we're gonna get out of this what is
that he why he figures out and it's and
you sort of wonder how could anyone not
figure this out I can use this this is
gonna work great for me I'm gonna be
able to not only they gonna look out for
me and make sure I'm okay
I'll keep talking to him what I can
cover my tracks on anything I can use
this I can send them off on people I
just want to get out of my way
oh that that's absolutely right I mean
you know right around the time that
whitey becomes an informant he actually
you know he's charged with 19 murders
when he goes to trial next week he's
charged with killing 19 people in the
70s and 80s but one of those people is
is a guy who had been kind of a rival
gang and eventually they they sort of
you know there was some mediation and
they all were gonna work together under
whitey but he still had it in his mind
that he wanted to wipe out these guys he
never really liked you know from this
rival gang so right after becomes an
informant
he's charged with taking this guy named
Tommy King killing him and it's a you
know a really interesting story because
they're riding in the car and they tell
Tommy that they're going to go to kill
someone else and Tommy has a bulletproof
vest on and he gets in the car and they
hand out guns to everybody in the car
and Tommy he gets a blunt you know
blanks and his gun and they and they
kill him
and and they bury him in a secret grave
and and then right around that same time
they decide to kill his friend a guy
named Buddy Lennon so they kill him so
now the meeting that whitey has with his
FBI handler he says to him hey John
Tommy King just killed buddy Leonard and
and he's gone into hiding well meanwhile
he's in a secret grave you know he's
dead so John Connelly writes it in the
FBI files you know that whitey had told
him that you know bodyline it was the
you know that Tommy King killed buddy
Leonard so now he waits a cotton and
this is disseminated to Boston Police so
they're looking for Tommy King and and
now he goes back a couple weeks later
because he's like you know they're gonna
be wondering we had Tommy went so he
updates the FBI and says well you know
they told Tommy you better get out of
town because you know you're gonna get
killed you don't want the cops process
any wait so he waits another few minutes
a few you know goes back later and he
says Tommy King's dead they killed him
they got him now you'll never find him
so so this is how he's you know
relating the FBI but over the course of
the years it actually gets much worse
and more sinister even than that because
what's at the allegations are that when
people went to the FBI to cooperate
against whitey they would leak it to
whitey hey and then he would kill them
and and so four of the people didn't see
the pattern and they really didn't care
about the patent so a number of the
victims in this case are FBI informants
and at some point you know as he's more
and more emboldened that he can get away
with anything you know now you know
later on we see you know businessman
legitimate businessmen who they're
shaking them down and they're not
killing them but summing them to
meetings and saying hey I'm gonna give
you a chance to buy your life you pay me
you know four hundred thousand dollars
and I'll let you live and by the way
don't go to the FBI because if you do
I'll know in five minutes he did the one
thing we wanted to do not one thing one
of many things we wanted to do was show
this that the the Justice Department
narrative of this being the for the
creation of one rogue agent who was too
close to the homeboy is baloney and that
this was thank you for saying baloney
the FBI and the Justice Department or
the Justice Department was absolutely
determined not to make this a big
scandal and so they didn't indict other
FBI agents by my count there was at
least a half dozen FBI agents that could
have easily been indicted including one
who called me in 1988 and said if I put
in the paper that Whitey Bulger was an
informant I would be murdered
now that agent Thomas Daly was allowed
to retire with a full pension and I was
subpoenaed back to testify in the
hearings the judge wolf convened
convened in 1997 and in 1998 I testified
to that about him calling me at the
globe saying if you do this
you will be killed now the government
had a chance to put him on to rebut my
testimony oh no it was you to the way he
did it gang snog he claimed that a
gangster called and wanted to pass over
this gangster didn't know me from a hole
in the wall there's no way a gangsters
got a say
really worried about Calvin you know but
but put it this way it doesn't matter
what what happened we have there's a
series of hearings I'm put up there I
testified for three and a half hours and
tell my story I have a contemporaneous
note that I was ordered to write after
the phone call by the editor of the
spotlight team the investigative unit
and the judge kept asking to the
government are you gonna put agent there
we understand to rebut mr. Collins
testimony they would not put him up
there because he would have perjured
himself or he would have taken the fifth
and they would have had to do something
they would have had to do something to
Tom Daly instead they just let him know
we're not gonna put them up the judge
says I accept mr. Collins testimony
especially given that you will not rebut
it and then agent Daly retires with a
nice full fat pension well I feel good
every time I fill out a tax form now
that's terrific that's the thing about
this I mean I you know we were talking a
little bit before we came out here about
how you know Whitey Bulger is one thing
it's it's what this says about the
Justice Department it's what this says
about the FBI I agree it's institutional
corruption at its worse yeah is it do
you think it's flushed down now no I do
I think will be really interesting is um
you know so Whitey's on the run for 16
years he's finally caught living in a
rent-controlled apartment in Santa
Monica California
two blocks from the beach where he in
fact had been living for 15 years and
it's a crazy story how he's caught it's
actually you know an a former a neighbor
who lives in you know her a former Miss
Iceland who lives in Santa Monica like
several months you know out of the year
and she's back home and Reykjavik and
she's watching a CNN report on the
latest campaign to try to find whitey
and she recognizes the wanted posters on
the you know of him and his girlfriend
and she knows them because Cathy his
girlfriend by all accounts lovely lovely
woman incomplete you know insist though
whitey could never have done all these
horrible things she loved animals and
she was feeding stray cats in the
neighborhood and
this font on a Bhushan's dota thought oh
how wonderful what a nice lady she's so
kind to that kid and she thought her
husband Charlie that's what he called
himself was a little cranky but she
recognized them called the FBI and
that's how they caught him and in fact
we have received you know for the book a
friend of Whitey's who has been writing
to him since his capture she had some of
those letters with us and I might add it
gives you a great insight into whitey
and Kevin and I have said why do you may
have a lot of problems but self-esteem
isn't one of them
but it but in one of the letters you
know he writes Oh a cat got me captured
the actually screwed up in the subtitle
you know the whole walk see the subtitle
America's most had said Whitey Bulger
how a cat caught America's most-wanted
gangster baby for the paperback I'm sure
he would love that he is a fan of
reading about himself oh yes absolutely
is he likes to read in general but he's
not particularly fond of the Boston
Globe because in 1975 he shot up our
offices oh because he opposed the way
the globe editorially supported busing
to it to desegregate the public schools
but the Boston Globe is in good company
because he also took took you know as
part of his I guess social outreach
campaign who went after John F Kennedy
firebomb Jack Kennedy's birthplace
because he was angry at the Kennedys in
general because the the the biggest
bogeyman in Southie that period was a
judge named W author Garrity he was a
federal judge Jack Kennedy made him the
US Attorney when he was elected and then
Bobby Kennedy promoted them through the
Justice Department and then Teddy
Kennedy became his not only his prime
mover to push him for a federal
judgeship
but then when Garrity issued that ruling
which is very controversial and in the
city but in Southie particularly was
seeing that they were foisting the
social experiment on like the poorest
people that couldn't and wouldn't affect
all the rich white suburbs which were
far more segregated in the city so they
hated the Kennedys and they really hated
more he really hated Teddy so he goes
and firebombs Jack Kennedy's birthplace
that he spray-painted outside in front
of the house busts teddy
what a swell guy meanwhile his his
brother is also fighting against the
egregore
the forced busing okay and and I think I
think when you look at this he said well
how much interaction was there I mean
was he really bad sheep today well what
I thought was really fascinating in
researching the book I traveled out to
California because white he had spent
nine years in federal prison as a young
man in the in the late 50s early 60s for
bank robbery and he sent and he was sent
to Alcatraz which was the first
maximum-security federal prison in the
country and and he looked at Alcatraz
very fondly like many of us might look
at our alma mater where we went to high
school we went to college he was very
proud of that and it gave him a lot of
stature in the Boston underworld because
people like hey Alcatraz you know but
but we have a chapter in the book called
university of alacant anybody can step
through Harvard that's exactly right and
and he actually you know was a high
school dropout who earned his GED while
he was in the Air Force but where he
really got educated himself was in
alcatraz where he he boasted that he
read a book a day became very well read
read military history you know read
Machiavelli and Kevin likes to joke most
wise guys think when they hear that you
know who Machiavelli is they go yeah I
think he's in the Cleveland crew but why
he actually took the lessons well but
one of the interesting things about you
had asked about the family dynamic is
that so here's why he's in prison his
brother Billy at the time is at Boston
College Law School and and he's really
you know he's five years younger than
whitey and he's determined to try to
help him go straight and he's lobbying
you know well he's at law school to try
to get whitey moved closer a prison
closer to home maybe get him early
parole and he enlists the Dean of the
Boston College Law School
father Bob Dryden to become white he's
sort of prison penpal he's writing to
whitey and this looks good for white
he's in prison and he's getting
letters from priests and you know this
looks like he's really trying to turn
his life around and so you know you see
this this priest who's writing trying to
help him you know even within the prison
system to do well he also gets on that
at the time the Speaker of the US House
John McCormack to lobby who's also from
South Boston to Lobby the prison the
Bureau of Prisons to try to get whitey
sort of special treatment you know gee
can you watch out for this guy he comes
from a wonderful family which he did can
you get him you know move closer to home
but why he gets caught up in a couple of
prison escape attempts and so he ends up
at Alcatraz
so the House Speaker Jack McCormick he
gets the head the director of the Bureau
of Prisons in Washington to fly to San
Francisco take the boat out to Alcatraz
and pay a little visit to Whitey Bulger
and he how they treatin you how you
doing here Jimmy
I mean how many penny-ante bank robbers
got visits from head of the Bureau of
Prisons so at a very early age why he is
seeing how political connections can
really pay off but he also when he got
out he became his brothers sort of
protective his brother was his protector
when he was in the can and when he got
out he got we found he got very involved
anybody he perceived as a political foe
of his brother that would include the
newspaper we work for it's an enemy and
why he would go after them and there was
a guy named Alan says it's key who
actually was a state senator who got up
and had the temerity to suggest it and
on the floor the Massachusetts Senate
that whitey that Billy Baltic controlled
all the legitimate interest in South
Boston and his brother the gangster
controls all the image of an interest
now Allen was actually in the midst of a
mental breakdown when he said it but was
no true words have ever been spoken on
the floor of the Massachusetts Senate
but why he had his henchmen Kevin weeks
who cooperated with us for the book
Kevin told us he called says is he
anonymously his house and said I'm gonna
kill you I'm gonna kill you that's the
kind of stuff that whitey did to anybody
he perceived as a threat to his brother
you know we're not we're not amateurs
when it
to families and politics and corruption
during County I do have the sense that
if you were the brother of a well known
mobster you might run into a few hurt
you know stumbles along the way it might
be a prominent how did his rise continue
while this was also going on that that's
one of the things that I think would
puzzle well I think that it was far from
the FBI protected and we know that is we
know but I also think that the
legitimate power that was white Billy
balls are silenced a lot of things now
first of all Billy Bulger had a huge
patronage machine I mean I had cousins
that got jobs that would have to have
been approved by the Bulger office
that's just the way it went and so that
a lot of people were coward by that
there also was just an enormous
intimidation factor I know that when in
Southie you weren't supposed to be
sitting around a bar room the 1980s
talking about Whitey Bulger that just
wasn't done and it was a real sense that
if you stepped over a line in South
Boston the funny thing is what we know
now is the Bulger organization was
purposely very small the criminal
organization but I think the perception
at least when I lived there was that it
was huge and that they were big brother
was everywhere and everybody was
intimidated but the other thing it's
like I said there were legitimate police
officers start trying to take out I mean
we there were very few heroes in that
book but some of them um named Bobby
long and Jack O'Malley and state cops
those those guys estate cops Rick
Fralick that there were three Boston
cops Frank Diwan Kenny beers Jimmy Carr
who were really trying to take him out
and DEA agents very good DEA agents and
they were getting screwed at every turn
they can't they're invested their
investigations were being compromised in
one case it was actually a corrupt FBI
corrupt state police officer who who
actually sorted an investigation or
undermined it and but everybody assumed
it was the FBI that was the other thing
when I like in the mid eighties when I
went to my editors and said I believe
what he's an FBI rat is the only
explanation for being on the street and
that wasn't just me thinking it up I was
hearing this from all those people I
just mentioned but they were so
frustrated at this point that they could
not take him down legitimately and in
one case there was
after the yep when this Bobby long in
the state cops went after him
somebody secretly inserted a rider into
the state police budget which killed the
salaries of for all the state police
commanders no one never figured out
happened but it happened in the state
Senate hmm I wonder who could have done
that dear you know the idea family comes
up in a lot of ways in this story and
and and in not all the conventional ways
of a of a mob story one is the the man
the way he well I mean he had a lot of
families didn't he well yeah I mean I
think that he you know and that to me is
one of the the interesting parts of the
story too is that you know here's a guy
who was he had so many he was very
complex I mean he had lots of he's an
FBI informant even though he denies that
he prefers the word liaison or analyst
but you know but he's an FBI informants
and at the same time he's that you know
the head of the underworld he also was
juggling lots of different women and one
of the most interesting parts of the
story is that he had these two of these
women where his longest relationships on
he had a young woman named Teresa
Stanley who he met when she was a single
mother with four children all under
seven years old he meets her shortly
after he gets out of prison in the 1960s
he never marries but he basically treats
her children as his own he buys her
house he moves around the projects and
and he insists on sit-down family
dinners every night around six o'clock
no interruptions no TV no phone calls
and he lectures the kids on the
importance of staying away from bad
influences he there were any kids they
were hanging out with and then you know
be physically fit study hard and the
course then he would go off into the
night and allegedly you know shaking
down drug dealers and bookmakers and
legitimate businessmen and the guy's
gotta earn the occasional murder and
then around it was sort of like a scene
out of fathers knows knows best the way
he treated those kids and then he would
go off like Iran
one or two in the morning when the bar
is closed on he would head to his other
girlfriends house now she was ten years
younger than Teresa
so of the thirty years that he was with
Teresa he's juggling this other
relationship for 19 of those years with
another woman Cathy Greig the one who
ended up with him on the run all those
years but a very interesting story she
was voted the prettiest girl in her high
school class but she never thought that
was good enough for YT she had all sorts
of cosmetic surgery done
she graduated from Northeastern
University with a bachelor's degree plan
to pursue some sort of career in the
health field ended up teaching at
Forsyth dental school in Boston but then
gave it all up quit just to basically
take care of him
and but it was very frustrated at being
the other woman all the time so she knew
she was the other she knew the other
Teresa didn't knew nothing about her
even though they both grew up in South
Boston but but but Cathy knew all about
Teresa
so as the clock is ticking and it's
clear that YT is under investigation and
you know he's likely to be indicted in
the fall of 1994 Cathy decides all right
I need to force him to make a decision
he has to choose between the two of us
so she calls Kathy up one night it says
we need to talk something bad is going
on in Teresa who's very sort of a
passive person you know okay
so Kathy picks her up brings it to her
house and she tells her you know you
know well for the last 19 years you've
been with him he's been you know he's
been with me for 19 over the last 30
years so it's very dramatic scene yt
walks in upon it treat Kathy's yelling
what could possibly go wrong according
to both Teresa who I did interviews with
and and one of Whitey's friends who was
there Kathy screaming I'm tired of being
the other woman and and Whitey's
strangling her on the ground and his
friend has to pull him off so the way
this resolves itself is he says that she
said all right it's over you're the one
I choose you
lucky Teresa because he was such a cat
right so she he takes her on this
whirlwind trip to Europe and but Teresa
thinks it's a vacation but wait he's
actually stopping and
no you know in London and Dublin and
Paris and he's hitting up safe deposit
boxes where he has stashed money and
fake ID because he's planning on a life
on the run so when they come back to
Boston within a matter of weeks
he gets the heads-up from John Connelly
you better take off you're about to be
arrested so he off he goes with with
Theresa but after about a month on the
run she says you know after the way he
raised my kids and took care of them you
cave you know walked her daughter down
the aisle and you know he said I she
said I would have felt obligated to stay
with him but now knowing that he
betrayed me all those years no I owe him
nothing take me home so he drops her off
just south of Boston takes up Kathy and
after they go and it's an amazing story
of how they lived on the run because
she's just so grateful to finally be the
only woman and he describes her as like
his wife they like this married couple
and she spends that in his letters that
we obtain so they're captured and she's
now serving eight years in prison
because she refused to cooperate against
him completely unrepentant but he's
writing letters from to his friend from
jail now saying those 16 years were the
happiest years of his life it was like a
16 year honeymoon and he says how dear
the government sentence her to eight
years in prison he said they should have
given her a medal because she did what
no law-enforcement person could ever do
and that was keep me crime free for 16
years he doesn't count the 30 guns he
had in the wall it's a love story well
it is a love story because he's working
so hard to keep her I mean he's saying I
you know do what you must with me but
how can you process that brings us men
circle to the myth-making because we got
the letter in which he said that he
offered himself up for execution if only
they would let the woman I love go free
that sounds very nice it is baloney I
did a guy because if whitey really cared
about Kathy all he had to do was go to
hear her lawyer
have his lawyer talk to her give me up
I'm gonna die in prison tell the feds
whatever you want and the feds would
have I no doubt in my mind they would
have severely reduced the sentence and
maybe not sentence her to any time in
prison if she cooperated but no she
wanted to be the Southie girl you know
stand by my man you know Tammy Wynette
in the background with us out the accent
it's but you know in it and that's like
I said it's full circle we talk about
whitey be the Miss making is the the
good bad guy who gives rise home to nice
old ladies and carries their groceries
for them full circle to whitey the 83
year old gangster doing 155 setup
push-ups on the floor of his 8 by 12
cell every day saying he'd die for the
woman he loved
it's baloney it's all myth its it was
meant for you to believe that he is a
good bad guy well there are two other
points to the you know reputation is
everything to him and what we know from
these letters that he's written
you know he's sort of resigned himself
to the fact that the chances that he
won't get acquitted that the trial
starts next week with openings probably
will run through the end of September
he says I'm probably gonna spend the
rest of my life behind bars he says he
wants to achieve achieve at this trial
and that is I was never enough FBI
informant and I did not kill those two
women two of the 19 victims are young 26
year old women that he's accused of
strangling and and let's face it good
bad guys gangsters with scruples
they don't rat on their friends and they
don't strangle women and the
gamesmanship is continuing to this day
and that you you just got word what
yesterday that you're actually gonna be
allowed to cover the trial because the
AG tried to stop that he put us on the
witness list because we would be such
good witnesses fine
I definitely would be a terrific defense
witness for whitey but I and I actually
fired back before the judge actually
sided with us after our lawyers made a
First Amendment argument basically
saying our First Amendment rights Trump
his Sixth Amendment right and but I
actually wrote a column which I'm sure
he was not very fond of because he
actually fired a motion back in US and
which I talked about the myth-making and
what he wants you to believe he's saying
and
why he has I guess what the
psychologists would call fits of
grandiosity and he likes to talk about
himself in literary terms he in one
letter he talks about what he has to
prove in court is his Gordian knot and
the other thing he said he loves he goes
I feel like Philip Nolan now Philip
Nolan is the pert ragunatha in that
great ed whatever at heel short story
man without a country it's about a noble
a flawed character who feels like he's
being persecuted by his own government
so that's how white he sees himself but
I ended my column saying he's no Philip
Nolan he's [ __ ] Nolan
[ __ ] Nolan was the portray Guiness in
the great short story by Lee molarity
called the informer and [ __ ] Nolan sold
out his friends from money well I have
to tell you the you know the department
was an interesting movie but this is
well why do you would not have liked the
way that Jack Nicholson portrayed him
because Jack was sort of wild hid and
unkempt and undisciplined a little
overweight you know yeah why he's like
much more disciplined and and and his
associates told us he would never come
you know like be that sort of
disorganized with blood on his hands
know why he wants to tell his story his
way he doesn't want people like us
defining him and that was you know in
terms of putting us on the witness list
if you're on the witness list generally
you're sequestered and that would have
been the point that we could not cover
the trial and and he's determined to
tell it his way in his letters he said
how dare those to write my story he
called me something that I can't repeat
on TV and he called Kevin another
lowlife just proves didn't get one thing
right well you know why he's not happy I
say no well that's okay yeah what the
book is is America whitey bulger
america's most wanted' gangster and the
manhunt that brought him to justice I
think we have a few minutes if there are
questions we have someone coming up to
the mic we ask that you use the mic
because otherwise people
where's Whitey Bulger and his brother
were they
Luise - Hicks and since he was a reader
did he ever read the book about his the
cover Boston during his heyday common
ground did he ever express an opinion on
that he did he believe he did and yes
they were big fans of Louisa Hicks and
there was a book when when he went on
the run the FBI seized you know a lot of
his belongings and among them was a book
that a teacher in Southie had written
called Southie won't go I'm not sure if
Colin I don't think common ground was
among those books but he was very
well-read and he read all of those and
he wrote about how much he well it was
interesting because in the book Southie
won't go she mentions the bombing of the
JFK birthplace and so they found
Whitey's copy the book and next to that
section where she mentions the bombing
he writes in the margins of the book too
bad
Ted wasn't in the house Mary Jo would
have been happy you know meaning married
okay okay great what yes so your book
shows us truth is stranger than fiction
absolutely Sopranos has nothing and what
this could be
you know if we are watching it but I
want to ask you to maybe step away from
the role as authors and and and how
close you are to this case but as
journalists if you were reading this
account and just how the FBI and people
we look to as citizenry to protect our
rights protect us how that compromised
your your livelihoods what you're
supposed to do the role of journalism
and if you could just comment on that a
little bit just professionally what you
uncovered and and and how you you feel
about that what journalists they I mean
that I'm glad you asked that because in
the sense that we're talking about what
he balls are being a you know basically
a sociopathic murderer killer
extortionists Paulo I expect criminals
to be like that I don't expect my
government to act the way they do in
this book and the one thing Shelley and
I really did want to show is that beyond
the individual corruption of Colin Lee
was the institutional corruption there
were when the FBI knew
he was a murderer that he was suspected
in several murders in the early 80s the
FBI lied to its own people at Oklahoma
that were investigating the murder and
threw them off the off the trail and
they compromised they consciously made a
decision to keep Bulger on rather than
turn him over to other law enforcement
agencies and the other thing that I
really deeply resent is the way that the
government has tried to suggest he was
only killing gangsters my government
doesn't get the pic who lives and dies
they I don't care if they're criminals
but the reality is Whitey Bulger killed
a number of innocent people Deborah
Davis was not a criminal Deborah Hussey
was not a criminal Michael Donnie was
not a criminal Roger wheeler was not a
criminal but the other thing that we
really did try to show - where is this
the sort of John Connolly taken money in
protecting this guy is like corruption
you understand corruption is quid pro
quos people get money to us corruption
goes to this day in the sense the
Justice Department did everything it
could to hurt the victims families and
would not acknowledge their hurt they've
never apologized them they've gone out
of their way to make sure the cases
seeking compensation have been thrown
out and the the the way the Justice
Department did it is so cynical because
on the criminal side they would go in
there and say John Connolly is a rogue
agent who killed got people killed and
he and the reason we know this is these
criminal associates of Whitey Bulger
John Montano Kevin weeks and Stevie
Flemmi say so and then that same Justice
Department would send their civil
lawyers into a different courtroom and
say oh these claims have to be thrown
out because you can't believe the word
of these gangsters that's that to me is
corruption that our government would do
that to these people well I thought just
too quickly that is one of the things
that I found most startling I mean we've
covered this story since the 80s but I
did find it startling that you know
afterward there were revelations in
court about the FBI's corrupt
relationship with with Bulger that it
led to a number of murders when the
families did file these wrongful death
suits alleging the government was liable
because of the FBI's handling of these
two informants whitey and his partner
Steve Flemmi
they manage the government managed to
get most of those suits dismissed on
technical grounds when they argued and
so they never got to have their day in
court and what they argued was you know
you should have known you knew sooner
you should have been watching TV you
should have been reading the paper more
closely you should have known a couple
years ago that the FBI was to blame and
you waited too long to sue because you
have to state your claim within two
years that are knowing you have a claim
and so they they were dismissed on those
grounds and to me that's just funny
proud moment one that we time for one
last question here I think you've
started to answer my question but it
seems like what you said at the
beginning was that Bulger was sort of a
perfect storm in terms of where he
happened to be and wonderful time in
place so is there are there other whitey
Bulger's and do you see that happening
again or the baby this is my argument I
I don't believe the culture of the FBI
has changed much and last year I did a
series of columns based on some
reporting that Shelly I and another
reporter at the club Milton Valencia did
in which we found a guy named Mark
Rosetti and I remember getting up on a
first phone call about this story by a
state cop who worked on the Bulge of
stuff and he called him a mini Bulger
now this guy was accused of being in
accused of suspected in six at least six
he's a mafia capo and he's a big mafia
guy and they rolled them and the state
police Massachusetts State Police
decided to target him because he was a
well-known heroin dealer he was not a
nice guy and so but they thought he was
an FBI informant so they called the FBI
this is just two years ago call the FBI
it said we think this is your guy we're
gonna move on oh no thought oh god
absolutely not as soon as they get the
wire up on there and think they get they
get wires on a subpoena they get a court
order to go on to this the gangsters
cell phone the first very first
conversation they record it's him
talking to his FBI handler san I think
the State Police are coming after me he
was right and when they took him down
that same FBI supervisor who said oh
he's not our guy talked called us a cop
commander and said hey that was a great
pinch you guys make
want to roll them together the stake off
Tony look Teddy goes roll them we're
gonna put him in prison and he said he
goes what are you guys crazy he's a
killer this guy's killed at least six
people and the FBI agents response to
him once we know of only one so dealing
with the guy that killed one person is
acceptable so you asked me has a change
I don't believe it's changed and that's
why I think I think the FBI needs an
enema I think the entire situation and
I'll go back to this I took it talk
about it in historical car I walked by
the Shelley and I'm in Washington last
week and I walked by the J Edgar Hoover
Building and I thought what a disgrace
that that name is still up there what we
know about that guy he was one of the
most corrupt government officials in the
history of this Republic and his name is
still on that building his ethos is
still in that building and that's why
all we talk about Whitey Bulger this
still is a mock Rossetti and on that
cheery note I'd like to thank you all
for coming out like to thank Charlie
Murphy Kevin :
Boston Globe the book is Whitey Bulger I
don't know how many of you are gonna
have time to come over to yes absolutely
I've got a session coming up in an hour
with Alan Sepinwall the book is the
revolution was televised but thank you
for this one lobby area and then they
will be signing them in the arts room
just to your left so thank you and we
ask that you do clear out the room we're
expecting a full house for the next
session so we need everyone to clear the
room to make sure that everyone is able
to get a seat
[Music]
our live coverage of the printers roll
it Fest continues in a few minutes